[Music]
nice to meet you nice to meet you what's
your name swad she put the brakes on you
know we so fire and roll up in a
wheelchair he's like so how is it down
there and the just stains out like
so I just wanted to roll you say yeah
yeah just chilling right now
recreational wheelchair you yeah giving
my my legs a day off yeah you walked in
I rolled it yeah and I'm a roll out roll
it what do you do for like hobbies for
fun okay I like to ski it's one of my
favorite things I like to go skiing I
like to travel a lot
I'm
sorry you look very tall and if you were
to push my wheelchair it would be very
uncomfortable for you really okay that's
my problem [__] how uncomfortable are
you with no legs whoa you mean it's
going to be uncomfortable for me I let
me decide if it's going to let me love
you that was a lot bro let me love you I
just want to love you baby how do you
feel about my mustache I've been trying
out the mustache look it's probably bold
but I'm kind of going it reminds me of
your eyebrows okay actually I've got a
lot of compliments on my eyebrows I mean
everybody's opinion is different do you
have any vets I do I have two golden
retrievers and two cats
so I'm sorry it was nice meeting you my
cat has
AIDS it has AIDS yeah I can't I can't
see somebody who has cats because my cat
has AIDS okay I Can't Stand Up and Shake
Your Hand oh you know it's good what's
your name uh I'm hey very good what do
you like to do I paint I rehab animals I
pop
wheelies yes I pop Willie that's my girl
I pop Willies
yeah I said roll and she said pop
Willies yo let's go my girl wheelies on
the on the on the chair yeah I can I can
do it L I'm impressed a no way and
that's crazy how you can maneuver on
that anyway I thought you were just
going to stay a place are you an active
person very yeah very I go on a lot of
hikes I run all the time oh yeah me too
all all of the running and Hiking I do
that
too I like how it's like are you very
active he's like yeah y r yay yeah we do
it
all he should have put his feet on the
table he said these
these these [__] that's when these legs
be become these nuts hey man you going
say I like exercising you know doing
physical stuff inste he went I like
hiking walking up tall steep mountains
and then when I get down I go for long
runs
stairs oh yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah
you got the special attachment SP is
talking all right you deserve to have
somebody that you can be active with you
shouldn't like settle for less than what
you want or what you deserve Let Me Love
You Man what's wrong with
you you know what I think because she's
in a wheelchair she already has to see
problems rolling in from a mile away
right
so okay let's keep going so you know
because has to she has to handle that
from a distance she's already
preemptively finding the reasons why
people might reject her because she's
probably already had that lived
experience I think I said this in a
previous
video we were talking about people with
handicaps and how hard it is for them to
date do you remember yeah I remember
that and what I was trying to say was
that people always make this idea like
oh if I'm in a relationship and they end
up in a wheelchair or they end up in
this situation I would say but the
reality is most people end up becoming
disabled end up losing their Partners or
a very large portion of them and the
people that do have these issues these
disabilities find dating to be quite the
struggle and so you're seeing it here
she before the person is even intimated
that they're having an issue she's
already anticipating because her lived
experiences or maybe it's her
insecurities who knows have told her
it's time to walk
away or roll
up but you're super chill yeah of course
you a real nice girl nice to meet you
nice to meet you you leaving ghosts um
well somebody was murdered at my house
and the doors do open a lot so really
that happens at my house too and there
was someone also allegedly murdered at
my house um tell me about yourself what
do you do for
fun sorry I just wasn't feeling it okay
do you believe in ghosts yes me too okay
cool what
do you believe in ghost yep me too do
you believe in ghosts do I believe in
ghosts
um I would say no what's your longest
relationship been uh it's not okay sorry
I'm sorry no you can sorry everyone you
didn't like d he apparently has been
asking everyone about the ghosts and
that kind of freaks me out that he just
keeps bringing up the ghost three ghosts
in a row three ghosts in a row I'm like
had to go what's your name I'm Paige
Paige I'm Sage nice to meet you oh
ni sorry
hi I'm Abba what's your name laba I'm
like that's a l literally Abba and labba
you wouldn't do it the fact that this is
all just young people is even worse not
because they're young but because
they're in school students are the most
[__] boring ass people to date they
just never shut the [__] up about their
degree oh my God studying oh my God
exams oh yeah it's September exams are
coming in 3 months but I want to stress
preemptively because that's what we
students do we just stress all the time
about exams that are coming down later
down the p oh my God I got homework
homework that counts towards my exams
and then I got a study for my exam I got
a paper do tomorrow which is an exam
what are you studying psychology you got
a useless [__] degree okay I'm so I
think I just might have some PTSD
because I never went to school and I
still dated a lot of people my age and
all they would whine I was like man I
got a job and I pay taxes and you ain't
never heard me moan this [__]
much you wanted to be a student that's
your job stop crying about it sorry I
have to get that off my chest that's a
pet peeve of mine that we could we saw
that hey that's fine if you're in the
audience am I lying about dating
students I don't think you are okay
that's really all they know I'm just
saying and they harder to Major the
words the people yeah
yeah wait I I was thinking if I disagree
with that I don't think I do though what
would your red flags be oh [__] um I'm
kind of toxic sometimes but what's your
definition of like toxic like if you
were to like describe a time you were
toxic what did you
do so what are your reflex no what like
what did you do when you were toxic um
just like I don't know play games a
little bit like to like see if she would
care yeah see if she like actually likes
me damn I really don't like the playing
games thing you know I be Wonder every
time these people fill out the
questionnaire the button just like tell
us your red flags and [__] just
be saying the most foul [__] just to
sabotage themselves like after the 20th
episode don't you realize just don't be
putting up one to go put up like yeah I
I ripped my [__] once and you know
the cup producer was like you you did
what with who that was a really
terrifying personal moment for you
fantastic how did you rip your butt how
did you rip your butt how's your anus
doing today and it's like the button
segs into these questions smoothly you
could just be like so what' you do for
the day I'm not oh yeah I went to work
great and the bud is like how's your
[__] Stephanie it's like what the
[__] it's so jarring it's not just the
what it is like the button is just like
it's random y it's random yay it's very
random uh Michael lost his toe while he
was in the middle of an orgy it's like
woo good luck this is a whole game of
recovery and you definitely could have
failed what you say is your favorite
movie I like always love to I have to
ask that back to the future oh that's a
great that's a great looks like an Asian
version of Jay
Leno
wild action that's like an unbelievably
good pick no mine would be for comedies
sha Shank Redemption is from what would
you say is your favorite movie I like
always love to I have to ask that back
to the future oh that's a great that's a
great pick actually that's like an
unbelievably good pick no mine would be
for comedies sha Shank Redemption is
from
did he see
comedy I think that's what he said shash
Shank Redemption yeah he said
that all right have you not seen oh my
gosh okay it's like it's a great movie
My favorite movie is I Robot makes sense
makes sense B I'm not president by the
way I'm not
president what are you looking for I
don't really want something super duper
casual but I'm also like not having to
be like oh I want to get married to
very middle Z we're figing out let's
just go on a date see how things are and
then we progress yeah from there figure
it out exactly yes so we go question
yeah how important are pets ooh that's a
great question are you a pet person um
yes okay are you yes I have a cat who is
my son like I got him when I was 15 and
22 now so I so he's about to
die carry on what you
mean life expectency you like my son you
know I got it when I
15 I'm 22 now he going to die soon
really how long do cats live uh maybe up
to 20 years top Max 20 years what top
really
top some of people who always have cats
so they just be cycling through new cats
all the time damn that's foul no depends
how you see it I know a lot of people
that cycle through new [__]
true
uh how long do dogs live on average um I
think it's
like s to eight years you can to have 10
years sometimes they push
15 really yeah it's not not what you
thought you thought what 30 years damn I
don't I don't that sounds tragic I you
try to get no pets that sound terrible
yeah people get attached and then they
die and get new ones and they die I go
through I don't know why that just
sounds crazy to me it's really what it's
really what it is
man yeah like they get they get so
attached and stuff like that and they
get so emotional I've seen some people
I've seen some people I've seen some
people like cancel shows because they
they pet die which makes sense which I
understand that but like every [__]
15 years that's if they're in a good
shape but listen I also don't understand
pet and Tyler CU I never have one so
like people are going to lose their
[__] minds I hat I just don't get it
but I don't hate on it it's just I would
have a hard time losing my pet every 10
15 years I'm also 22 So Co oh solid um
my cat luuka love him I'm also going to
name my son or daughter Luca interesting
um you already you already planned it
out I planned it out because that cat is
amazing I also have um my dog I just got
him a month ago and he's a pitsky pit
husky yeah oh my yeah it says so much
about someone if they're like you can
have an animal and keep it alive and
healthy happy I think he's happy too it
makes you think I think he's happy like
when I come home from school he like
freaks out and it makes me really happy
that's actually really cute are you twoo
attracted to one another I I am yeah
yeah she's cute she's very cute I'd say
you're cute I really like your eyes and
your smile thank you I said the eyes but
I don't know she just has there's like
this radiant energy I don't know it's
just the lighting but she just like
really it's okay they're too really into
each other yes yes yes but Jesus Christ
does he talk a lot my God you know what
someone like that cuz they don't like
having the top yeah so they prefer a guy
who asks a bunch of questions I guess
I'm going to line up red one more time
you want to go on a second day don't
press button
oh I just wish she would hit the button
like I saw sha shank and it's not a
comedy [__] [__] cuz that's one of
the greatest movies of all time and you
calling it a comedy is really disgusting
it's like watching
[__] rush hour and being like that's
one of the greatest deepest
drama I know just it really threw me
when he said it was a comedy Kidd I'm
kidding kidding I'm off I'm off I'm L
energy right
now oh my God look at it
he did it hi hello what's your name
Willa what's your name will I'm Robbie I
love your tattoos thank you so fun story
I bought a tattoo gun um I have a doodle
bob you ever watch SpongeBob as a kid
yes yeah I freehanded a doodle bob wait
show me I'm cool showing it but I'm I'm
going to have to drop my draws like my
overalls a little bit that's pretty good
see that how old are you I'm
21 I'm 18 you're 18 yeah that's okay is
it yep
that's I think the age my is kind of
freaking me out yeah yeah so you're a
freshman
what say when did 18 year olds get
freaked out by 21 year olds is that a
thing it's a thing maybe now we know
we're in that weird period is understand
what I'm saying we're now maybe the
weird period of
of i as well and stuff like that
happened and there's the young teens
there's some people that's all they know
about so at her age that's all she knows
about and when that thing happened so
peep game that thing happened in 2017
2016 right so that was 7 years ago she
was
11 so if she was 11 that's what when she
was in school everybody was talking
about that and people were maybe
conscious about that she was not even
she was not even in high school she was
in elementary school and then went to
high school you understand what I'm
saying I know some teachers were really
prone prone to to talk to their children
about what happened in Hollywood and
this and that and the age Gap and AG
this and that so so it's very possible
that that because of the age that she is
18 and that pretty and that time really
affected her I remember some things that
happened when I was 11 and it shift the
way people were in our classes we had to
put move the curriculum away and talk
about those events you know what I mean
when I was a young kid so these things
and this was pretty big in worldwide so
worldwide westwide should I say should I
say so it's possible that this affected
her her way of viewing the world and
viewing people that are older as far as
dating like you're 21y old no you can't
cuz there going to be power and this and
that and whatever maybe that affect her
yes oh um where you from Bay Area San
Francisco oh yeah why why is that bad
it's not bad it's just like all the um
out of state kids are from Bay yeah okay
how important is sex in your
relationship I just remember who this
girl
is the Virgin girl with the boobies out
yeah hello hello what brings you here
tonight this one te I'm like I recognize
those twins how y'all do oh yes I
remember who they were attached to mhm
yeah maybe that's what it is yeah well
vir so what do you count as body count I
just don't count or okay
be hot she sucked off like the whole
football team her definite version just
didn't put it in the pom poom but she
could blow out 100 dudes and it's okay
uh it's it's it's it's decently
important yeah I have not had sex so
yeah that's we'll see okay yeah of
course I feel like the button trying to
put you on the spot I I feel I want to
be uncomfortable here okay okay no it's
it's totally go butt
yeah that's okay definitely like a
friendly buy but not a romantic
chemistry personally is what I felt yeah
definitely wasn't a sex thing that's not
Li well there you go that was it for
today's button video uh young
people doing
some that was very insightful
thanks that's all I really got for y'all
anything else you want to say preach no
all right let us know what you guys
think in the comments how do cats get
AIDS